Matt Matt Rose who's a professional
poker player has made more than 2
million make playing poker he's won the
World Series of Poker told me about how
he goes about planning for a poker
tournament at poker game and so he sets
out he thinks about scenarios he might
face in the moment that would cause him
to make sort of rash decisions like he's
next to a player who's got a lot of
bravado who he's played against in the
past and he's gonna be tempted to just
kind of whatever just lay it all out
there and do something that doesn't make
sense he's also gonna think about card
combinations so he's very mathematical
the way he plays and he'll think about
scenarios he could face at the poker
table and what he would do under each of
them based on what the odds will be so
he actually does some forecasting like
that and basically that is a version of
a technique that's been studied by Peter
gollwitzer who's a-- and weiu professor
who's documented this in sort of many
many dozens of settings called if-then
tactics and these works very well for
New Year's resolutions by the way so if
you if you have a new year's resolution
and you're just telling yourself you
know I'm gonna go to the gym five days a
week or three days a week we all know
how that usually turns out you something
happens right you end up there for me
it's like okay it's really cold since I
live in Boston it's really cold this
morning I want to go to the gym but I
just I just like don't I just want
another hour of sleep and let it warm up
a little bit and then I then I'll just
go to work and so if you're doing an
if-then tactic what you would do is you
would say if I'm okay I'm gonna make the
resolution gym three days a week if it's
really cold in the morning then I will
and then I state some sort of positive
thing I will do that will get me to
actually do this thing so if it's a
really cold morning I will turn up like
the hip hop really loud at 6 a.m. and
that'll get me out of bed and then I'll
then I'll go to the gym so it's sort of
anticipating all the hurdles that might
get in the way of your long-term goal
and thinking of those short-term hurdles
and then stating affirmative ly what
you'll do to avoid them and this by the
way it was also has also been shown to
you
in classrooms where teachers have
implicit bias when disciplining
schoolchildren so there's this pattern
in which black and brown students are
sent to the principal's office more
often in classrooms across the country
and that has disproportionate impact on
their outcomes in life because if you go
to this it's just sugar that's out of
school you go to this principal's office
to more likely to be suspended if we're
going to be suspend you're more likely
ended up in the prison system this is
this whole chain of events and it starts
with the teacher and the student in the
classroom and teachers that I
interviewed who'd used these techniques
had found a way to actually change some
of the outcomes in their schools and
their classrooms and what they do is say
okay I know that there's certain
students that just irritate me or I know
if I haven't eaten enough I'm going to
end up disciplining my students too
harshly so if a student acts up in class
then I'm going to first drop my pencil
and count to three before I decide what
to do with the student and it's
basically a way of planning ahead for a
situation that's prone to an impulsive
reaction and it has been shown to have
some at least some some preliminary
positive results in preventing people
from acting on their implicit bias all
right so what the poker player was to
not make an emotional play if they if
they're prepared for every card
combination and the teachers case not
make an emotional play when angry with
the student right right yeah and it's
sort of an emotional play and one that's
just based on that immediate impulse
instead of maybe what a lot of these
teachers write they don't want to
actually be doing this they just find
themselves in the moment making those
decisions but if they really think about
what's good for the long-term goals of
their students or the classroom it's not
necessarily sending the kids to the
principal's office